we got to talk about uh uh Hassan Minaj
yeah we do free Hassan like we've been
saying yeah we have this whole time we
were saying I was a lying ass [__] in a
New Yorker yeah absolutely how dare she
absolutely how dare she tell the exact
truth and then him go on camera and say
yeah you were right but but you were
wrong yeah no I will say this I was
right about the the high school girl
remember I said the high school girl was
racist m M you were right about that cuz
I said he was too cute to be rejected so
it had to be racism I knew it I knew
what I was right about that one but the
other two ones yeah he did lie about it
yeah yeah right I mean if a white powder
falls on my daughter I don't think if
it's a prank I'm going to be like we
don't need to check this out we don't
need to go to the hospital she got it's
a prank yeah I think you're going to be
like hey there's white powder on my
daughter let's go to the [__]
hospital just to make sure she's not
dying yeah let's call a doctor I'm
Indian I probably know some doctors
let's just see what's going on true I
just think the same thing you exists the
you know from the last conversation we
said where it's like if you're lying to
make it funnier it's great do it and if
you are lying to be some sort of hero or
to increase victimization then it's
corny yeah and I don't think he said
anything in the video that disputed that
yeah outside of the girl situation which
I knew she was a [__] racist [__]
this whole time I knew that that's
married to a brown guy that's what she
is a guilt yeah that's what these white
people do they're guilty bro they marry
what they
hate they're like I need to make their
lives miserable they hate us so they
make us Bro think about if you if you're
a woman you hated Brown men what's the
number one way to drive one [__]
crazy marry that brown [__]
you're going to be miserable you want
him to get Driven Crazy let him marry a
brown girl that's true I mean but
they're selfish these white women are
selfish they want to inflict the pain
true they don't want to give all that
joy to a brown woman to drive a brown
man crazy they're like n that's for
me so yeah free Hanan from that white
[__] yeah fre free Hanan bro but I got
to say he's [__] fantastic did you
guys watch the video watch He's
fantastic like even though the whole
time he's just saying exactly what
everybody criticized him for he's going
yeah I did lie to increase victimization
which is the criticism he's not saying
oh I didn't lie to make it funner he's
like I lied to increase victimization
and the whole time I'm watching it and
going I know you're
agreeing with the criticism but you're
saying it in a way that vindicates you
yeah and I agree with you yeah this
guy's good that's how I felt after for
real Hamas need to hire
him do you know what I mean like for
profit or the IDF but one of them need
to get on this [__] for real
both sides I mean incredible yeah yeah
he's very Charming he's Charming yeah
yeah white [__] devil how dare she how
thises white devil play him like that
how dare she and how she blame on her
family when you knew it was her that's
[__] up maybe she loved him so much
she was like I can't make this brown guy
miserable oh I got to find the next one
true love it might have been true love
holy [__] that's beautiful but yeah I
think that's really the issue but and he
got to get these jokes man you're gon to
get these jokes if you do some goofy
[__] like that you're G to get these
jokes you know but it was very well done
I'm not going to lie it was handled very
well he's a smart guy dude it was
handled very very well the kid's good
yeah mhm the kid's
good I think he went a little easy on
the white girl though she should have
got it worse what would you have done I
would have dox her
what do you know what that means yep
what does it mean so when you send a
white powder to their that's not that's
not an that's dochin I thought when you
send a white powder to somebody and you
open it you know how you open envelopes
over your kid's head always you know how
when you're going through mail you put
your kid right underneath it and then
you open it up yeah that's what I
thought it is especially when I'm
getting death threats that's why I want
a daughter exactly I just want her to
open it for me yeah when I get a piece
of meal from a no return address I just
get my child and then I open it up
upside down over them just in case cuz
you never
know do you know what I mean yeah you
can't have it land on me yeah and then
you got this white [__] this white
[__] dude you know what I mean this
white [__] that's how dare she that's
the issue with this white [__] take
down Hanan
minhaj guys that's his name why are we
even laughing at that that's how you
pronounce his name EMP on in a way I
didn't expect Minash yeah I that sounds
correct I'm pronouncing it correct M
Hassan Hass
minj what's going on I don't know how
he's in a loop he's in a feedback I I
think I am I think I am so free Hanan
free Hassan lock up the white [__] and
then third of all we need to get this
guy hired for some sort you know who
needs him bad right now Ukraine bro cuz
all the Energy's in the Middle East
nobody's giving a [__] about Ukraine
anymore they need a great propagandist
that can sell you anything and I don't
know if there's anybody better than
hussen menj right now he could be
president bro he could be president H
you really want to take down Trump take
down Trump holy [__] that would be fine
that' be kind of awesome actually holy
[__] yeah yeah born in very racist DAV
California racism in Northern California
I don't know if you no Indians a lot of
racism I need to see that acceptance
speech from him when he gets up there
and he's like four score and seven
years our
forefathers all right guys we're going
take a break for a second before I talk
about this next sponsor I want to tell a
quick story uh I got to meet a dude
named sad chowri and uh he' been a fan
for a while big fan of the flagrancy and
uh and the standup and when I was in
London we met him after the show Royal
Albert Hall and um when we were talking
I didn't know that he was going to be
one of the sponsors of the show but he
told me when he was listening to the pot
earlier on he was developing his career
he was making these video games he's
like one day I want to be able to
sponsor flagrant that would be so
incredible and his career started to
rise and our show started to get more
popularity and we had this cool
conversation the bows of Royal Albert
Hall um where he's like I can't believe
we're going to sponsor it I'm like oh
what is it and basically he created the
number one pool uh game in the world I
mean they have over 1 billion downloads
10 million people playing it every
single day I mean they it's it's really
amazing it's called eightball pool
anyway I thought it was really cool that
[__] Army member uh had built a
business and um and now we're actually
getting to you know work together which
is pretty [__] awesome so uh I want
you guys to all go check out his game um
they've got real multiplayer weekly
events tournaments happening all the
time and in fact what we're doing is
we're working on setting up an exclusive
flagrant collab so we'll have more
details dropping soon but for now I want
you to download eightball pool on your
phone you can download for free okay you
can even uh scan this QR code and you
start playing into practice you get to
level five to be involved because the
number one flagrant player is in for two
tickets to one of my shows flights and
ACC combination paid for they got it so
uh shouts aside man congratulations on
all your success keep on building we're
going to keep on building and uh really
cool to be working together so make sure
you don't miss this okay we're all in
major announcement cooking up with
eightball pool very soon and um yeah uh
I'm I'm stoked for you my bro very
stoked for you dude continue success and
it's fun too I suck at regular pool like
I play this I'm so bad at regular pool I
could play this I'm actually shocked or
bad at pools so bad you have good
coordination I know you would think and
I would you would think I would know the
angles but no it just don't I'll hit
like two or three amazing shots and then
miss eight in a row huh that don't make
any sense yeah you like so my head a
little bit yeah that's like really
surprising we were even talking about
you with uh we we were playing padell
and um why you're good at it I mean like
you still have to get the tennis rust
off but like you're just naturally
coordinated yeah more than it look like
I wouldn't yeah I wouldn't say you're
like freakishly athletic yeah but your
coordination yeah like you you can pick
up dance moves really well like you just
be a practi is in a bar by yourself you
know yeah absolutely no no I'm I know
you're [__] with buz and balls but I
mean that sincerely like so pool seems
like seems like it would be and it
drives me crazy I think it's too much
time to think I need something that's a
little bit more reflexive but I can't
really think just get it you're getting
in your head about the shot oh do I have
the angle right yeah am I hit it too
hard too soft am I going to leave it in
the where ping pong you don't have time
to react it's very quick all reaction
you don't have time to think yeah okay
all right that makes sense I can I can
get on board with that also use a promo
code Schultz you get your initial
deposit matched up to $100 that mean you
put in 100 get 100 for free so you might
as well just do it respect shout out
prize picks man